und jetzt das heute journal mit hanna
zimmermann und wohl schließe guten abend
nun beginnen überall in deutschland
außer ganz im süden die ferien letzter
schultag war heute in hessen im saarland
und in rheinland pfalz und hier habe ich
übernommen weil die kolleginnen und
kollegen aus geflogen sind wobei das mit
dem fliegen konkret zum problem werden
kann am frankfurter flughafen dem
drehkreuz schlechthin in deutschland
herrschte heute high noon die hier die
haben ihr gepäck noch immerhin denn auf
dem flughafen der türmen sich berge aus
tausenden von koffern auf die niemand
mehr warten konnte oder warten wollte
ein ziemliches durcheinander über dass
wir gleich mit dem chef der fraport ag
sprechen werden der
betreibergesellschaft des flughafens
aber erst zeigt uns seiner santina was
da heute los ist wohl immer noch ist und
wie sich die probleme türmen
rund 200.000 passagiere wurden allein
heute am größten deutschen flughafen
abgefertigt schon in den letzten tagen
kam es zu vielen flugannullierungen was
zu langen warteschlangen vor den
umbuchungen schaltern führte wie diese
handy aufnahmen zeigen viele machen sich
sorgen wenn man nicht weiß ob der flug
doch noch abgesagt wird und wieder
verschoben wird das ist schon hektik
irgendwie die sorge ist da aber wir
haben das wichtigste im handgepäck
tatsächlich haben wir auch er tags
unser gepäck gepackt dass er so grob mal
wissen muss dann am ende landet fraport
hatte während der pandemie 4000 stellen
abgebaut die fehlen nun was in den
letzten tagen zu solchen bildern führte
die koffer zu spät angekommen die
passagiere sind weg 2000 herrenlose
gepäckstücke lagern bis heute in einer
halle um ein chaos zu verhindern hat die
lufthansa in frankfurt und münchen fast
6000 flüge gestrichen auch heute gab es
annullierungen um eine überlastung
auszuschließen aber die gute nachricht
ist 99 prozent aller ferienflüge
operieren wie geplant und sind davon
nicht betroffen die mitarbeiter der
passagierabfertigung erleichtert das
nicht hohe krankenstände und tausende
flugannullierungen bleiben vor allem an
ihnen hängen das belaste sie sehr sagt
kristin die nicht erkannt werden will
seit 30 jahren arbeitet sie am flughafen
sie habe angst vor den passagieren
wir sind schon stundenlang in der
schlange gestanden beim check in kommen
dann zum boarding und erfahren dann dort
dass ihr flug spontan gecancelt wird wie
sind aggressiv die sind teilweise
übermüdet und wir müssen das ganze aus
baden die attraktivität des flughafens
als arbeitsplatz ist längst verflogen
flughafenbetreiber gründen tochterfirmen
mit dem ziel lohnkosten zu reduzieren
auch die passagierkontrolle wurde von
privaten sicherheitsfirmen übernommen
insgesamt gehe es darum teure
langjährige mitarbeiter loszuwerden sagt
paulas lockt man hat mitarbeiter in die
arbeitslosigkeit gedrängt gekündigt
viele gestandene mit beschäftigte saßen
bei mir im büro und haben geweint um
ihren arbeitsplatz dass die existenz
verlieren und solche mitarbeiter seien
nicht bereit zurück zu kommen zeigt sich
dieter menger von der gewerkschaft ag
überzeugt er macht für das chaos vor
allem die vorstände von lufthansa und
fraport verantwortlich bei der lufthansa
hatten wir im januar 90 prozent der
buchungseingänge von der vorkrisenzeit
wenn ich 30 prozent weniger personal
habe und nicht so dementsprechend stark
wieder das personal nach gesetze kann
ist völlig klar dass ich in den
sommermonaten dem rücken zur wand stehen
flughafen chef schulte hat eingeräumt
dass die probleme in frankfurt noch
andauern werden
und der ist nun hier live aus frankfurt
der fraport chef der auch präsident des
verbands aller deutschen
verkehrsflughäfen ist gut namens stefan
schulte
sie sind vorhin gelandet vor gar nicht
langer zeit zurück aus peru umstieg in
amsterdam sie haben bestimmt ihr gepäck
bekommen oder
ich will mich handgepäck geflogen in
diesem fall aber ich kann ihnen
versichern alle maßnahmen sind derzeit
darauf ausgerichtet dass alle flüge
rausgehen dass die passagiere in den
urlaub fliegen können und zwar mit ihrem
gepäck wenn wir heute den ersten tag
neben matthes im großen ganzen gut
funktioniert wir hatten sehr moderate
wartezeiten in der regel nicht über 20
25 minuten es war eine stabile operation
zum teil mit und möglichkeiten das gebe
ich zu aber im grossen ganzen hat
funktioniert naja ist auch der anfang
erst dieser reisewelle und des pc's
tausende koffer nicht abgeholt wie kann
das sein
wir sind inzwischen bei wenigen hundert
kopf von die noch am flughafen sind
alles anderes abgearbeitet aber die
haben recht ja wir haben eine schwierige
operation
es ist ein sehr schwieriges jahr für uns
der luftverkehr kommt aus der tiefsten
krise aller zeiten jahresanfang hatten
wir nun 20 30 des verkehrs der hochlauf
war erwartet worden aber er ist noch mal
viel viel stärker als erwartet und das
trifft dann auf ein system was ganz ganz
vernetzt ist dass viele partner umfasst
und was nicht so schnell wieder so sich
eingespielt hat was aber dann auch das
ganz offen auch luftraum kapazitäten hat
die begrenzt sind denn wir haben einen
krieg bekommen wir haben einen luftraum
westlich von uns der leider sehr stark
reduziert ist wer beim luftraum west die
vernunft der durch neue software updates
in frankreich sehr stark reduziert ist
und dann spielt sich an so hat natürlich
bin unpünktlichkeit von anderen
flughäfen die potenzieren sich hier in
franken herr schulte sie sagten aber das
aufkommen war erwartet worden aber im
grunde unterschätzt worden
jetzt sind sie der manager sie sind ja
seit fast 20 jahren im vorstand der
fraport
vielen jahren auch der chef
wie kann das sein dass man sozusagen
dieses aufkommen sich so vertan hat dass
man jetzt 20 prozent weniger mitarbeiter
hat die man eigentlich brauchen würde
ist welche fehler haben sie gemacht sie
persönlich herr schmid wir hätten noch
früher einstellen müssen wir stellen uns
schon seit herbst letzten jahres wieder
ein werden über 1.000 mitarbeiter neu
eingestellt aber wir treffen auf einen
arbeitsmarkt der schwieriger ist als
erwartet dass es vollkommen richtig weil
wir hier in der region vollbeschäftigung
haben wir stellen längst ein auch aus
dem außereuropäischen ausland spanien
griechenland balkan und wir haben jetzt
auch die initiative der bundesregierung
dass wir auch außerhalb der eu
einstellen können zumindest befristet ja
wir wussten dass dieses jahr schwierig
wird wenn sie aber dann keinen puffer im
system haben bei so vielen akteuren die
dort mitspielen müssen und sie haben
dann noch mal fünf prozent mehr verkehr
und sie haben dann lufträume die
begrenzt sind dann wird es eben
schwierig und das muss ich wirklich mein
kompliment sagen alle miteinander
arbeiten intensiv daran dass es hat ihn
zu stabilisieren klassenraum gegen
frankfurt auch hinbekommen das ist
anders als in amsterdam das ist eure
mitarbeiter teils hilflos aber auch tun
was sie können aber die kriegen den
ärger ja auch haben wir gerade gesehen
im bericht sie haben 4000 mitarbeiter
entlassen teils denen noch abfindungs
prämien gezahlt wegen corona damit ideen
und nun bieten sie wieder prämien an
weil sie händeringend leute suchen ich
meine wie wollen sie denn ihre fraport
ag wieder zu einem attraktiven
arbeitgeber machen
um abfindungen bezahlt dort im
administrativen bereich nicht in dem
bereich wo jetzt die bottleneck sind
dorthin wir leider beschäftigte verloren
weil wir eben gar keine beschäftigung
mehr hat er hat über monate hinweg gar
keinen flugbetrieb und dann hatten sie
attraktive angebote hier aber wir sind
ja wie gesagt hat ein dreiviertel jahr
schon wieder am markt und beschäftigen
intensiv stellen wieder neue 1000
mitarbeiter haben wir wieder neu an bord
ich gehe davon aus dass wir in zwei drei
monaten dadurch sind und der der
arbeitsplatz ist der attraktive sehen ja
wir können jeden monat über 100
mitarbeiter einstellen das funktioniert
wir müssen aber jetzt auch noch durch
die zuverlässigkeit überprüfung durch
die ausbildung die fortbildung wie z und
das nicht nur bei uns das ist in herborn
sie in so eine bisher stabil hingekriegt
wir haben keine terminal schließen
müssen wie london oder heutigen amerika
wurde zum schulterschluss möglicherweise
liegt es auch an weil sie eine ag sind
weil sie aktionäre im nacken haben die
sozusagen auf sparen und auch auf hire
and fire setzen wer ist besser ist wäre
staatlich
also hire and fire ist nun wirklich
nicht unsere positionen sondern wir sind
für stabile arbeitsverhältnisse und wir
haben sehr stabile sehr langjährige
zugehörigkeit dauern aber wir haben im
moment das gebe ich sie darauf hin zu
einem produkten es entschuldige ich mich
auch bei allen passagieren für mit dem
wir nicht zufrieden sind weil die
nachfrage noch einmal viel stärker ist
als erwartet und restriktionen auf der
gleichen seite haben herr schulte ich
danke den start gehen wird die
sicherheitskontrollen ag das lassen wir
als thema angehen ich danke ihnen und
alles gute weiterhin
ein einzelner hand wenn irgendwo vater
staat einsteigt dann ist es ernst in der
korona krise hatte der staat der
lufthansa sie erinnern sich milliarden
gegeben um sie vor der pleite zu retten
und heute da hat er sich wieder an einem
großen unternehmen beteiligt das
vielleicht noch wichtiger ist juniper
juniper das ist der energiekonzern der
versorgt etliche stadtwerke in
deutschland mit gas und damit sehr sehr
viele von uns immer wenn es so eine
teure und weitreichende entscheidung
gibt dann fallen große worte die
geschichte machen
hier 2008 in der finanzkrise als
kanzlerin merkel versprach die
spareinlagen sind sicher oder hier 2012
in der euro krise als der ezb chef
draghi zusagte whatever it takes wir tun
was auch immer nötig ist um den euro zu
erhalten
und heute zur gaskrise und juniper
rettung da hat bundeskanzler olaf scholz
ebenfalls einen prägenden slogan
verwendet mit dem 27 seinen bericht aus
berlin beginnt you never walk alone
dass wir gemeinsam die schwierigen
zeiten bewältigen dass wir
zusammenhalten dass es entscheiden es
ist ein signal des mutes dass der
kanzler heute vermitteln will in einer
zeit die voller unsicherheit steckt
scholz hat seinen urlaub unterbrochen um
zu verkünden dass der staat beim
gasversorger juniper einsteigt wir
werden als land
stabil durch die herausforderung kommen
die uns angesichts des russischen
angriffskriegs auf die ukraine auf den
energiemärkten begegnen juniper ist
deutschlands wichtigster gas-importeur
gilt als systemrelevant und ist in
schieflage geraten
konkret kauft der bund neue juniper
aktien im wert von 267 millionen euro
die regierung verpflichtet sich bei
bedarf bis zu 7,7 milliarden zur
verfügung zu stellen ein bestehender
kredit wird von zwei auf neun milliarden
euro erhöht man will als unternehmen
nicht in diese situation kommen beim
start anzuklopfen hier kommt geld der
steuerzahler zu hilfe einem unternehmen
beim start angeklopft hatte juniper vor
zwei wochen bei russland lieferungen
drosselt muss das unternehmen auf dem
teuren weltmarkt nachkaufen nur so kann
es seine verträge erfüllen etwa mit mehr
als 100 stadtwerken im ganzen land
deshalb das rettungspaket außerdem soll
juniper spätestens ab oktober die
gestiegenen kosten an die verbraucher
weitergeben können damit drohe dass das
problem verlagert wird so kommunale
versorger wir müssen damit rechnen dass
viele kunden diese mehrkosten nicht
bezahlen können und die sorge ist dass
die zahlungsausfälle bei den stadtwerken
dann dort zu wirtschaftlichen problemen
führen können niemand könne sagen wie
sich der gaspreis entwickelt sagt der
kanzler heute und präsentiert neben dem
rettungspaket für juniper auch weitere
entlastungen für die bevölkerung ab
nächstem jahr soll hartz iv durch ein
bürgergeld ersetzt werden mit deutlich
höheren regelsätzen
außerdem sollen die bürger leichter an
wohngeld kommen für studierende soll es
hilfe bei den heizkosten geben bei der
opposition stoßen diese ideen auf
skepsis
ich weiß nicht ob das genügt ich weiß
aber auch nicht ob der bundeskanzler auf
eine goldader gestoßen ist in seinem
urlaub das muss ja auch alles finanziert
werden fragen uns wo das geld herkommen
soll
niemand wird allein gelassen es ist ein
kaum zu halten das versprechen der
kanzler wird sich daran messen lassen
müssen
jetzt fließt wieder geld das ist ein
trugschluss denn das staatsgeld das sind
schulden jetzt fließt wieder gas auch
dass es nicht sicher denn putin hat uns
mit seinem gashebel weiterhin in der
hand und deshalb sind städte und
gemeinden in deutschland längst
angewiesen dringend zu sparen energie zu
sparen peter böhme zeigt uns wie das
läuft wie sie sich in den rathäusern
einrichten auf lange nicht gekannte
notzeiten
des essener rathaus über 1000 menschen
arbeiten hier könnte sein dass sie es in
zukunft im winter ein wenig kälter haben
werden und im sommer etwas wärmer weil
man die klimaanlagen höher dreht die
stadt hat eine task force gegründet die
ausloten soll wie können wir energie
einsparen bei den städtischen immobilien
im sportbereich den verkehrsbetrieben
also dass jede kilowattstunde zählt sehe
ich so und es ist aber auch wichtig dass
sie zeitnah vor der heizperiode bereits
maßnahmen einleiten damit sie in der
heizperiode dann auch die erfolge
einfahren können zb durch raumtemperatur
absenkungen in diesem jahr rechnet die
stadt mit mehr ausgaben für energie vom
30 millionen euro für die städtischen
immobilien allein etwa 21 millionen für
die rollbahn 4,6 millionen
für die messe mit vier millionen euro
der oberbürgermeister für markige worte
einstellen dass wir teil eines krieges
sind denn auch ein gaskrieg ist ein
krieg der uns unmittelbar betrifft und
offenbar sind die szenarien die auf
russischer seite durchaus eine rolle
spielen darauf müssen wir uns einstellen
und deshalb sollten wir jetzt uns auch
vertraut machen mit szenarien von gas
mangel lagen die wir vielleicht noch vor
einem jahr als völlig undenkbar erachtet
haben
undenkbar ist nichts mehr in den
schwimmbädern wie hier im
niederrheinischen willich haben sie die
wassertemperatur gesenkt das machen
viele kommunen zwei grad weniger bringen
bis zu 25 prozent energieeinsparung sagt
die deutsche bädergesellschaft
die kommunen kommen nicht zur ruhe eine
krise nach der anderen kommunen frist ja
einiges auf ob die korona krise das wo
wir heute alle große schäden hatten aber
jetzt natürlich auch bei der energie
thematik wir rechnen mit rund
dreieinhalb millionen euro mehr
energiekosten in hilden bei düsseldorf
haben sie entschieden in sporthallen und
schulen bis ende september warmwasser
und heizung abzustellen je nach wetter
wollen sie aber flexibel reagieren geht
darum wenn wir im september eben ganz
kalte tage haben kälteeinbruch dann
schalten wir natürlich die heizung
wieder vorher ein wenn sich die warme
zeit verlängert bis in den oktober
hinein dann würden wir die maßnahmen
noch weiter aufrecht erhalten die frage
ist ob und wie die kommunen die
explodierenden mehrkosten finanziell
wuppen können der deutsche städtetag
fordert hilfsprogramme die kommunen sind
an der grenze ihrer leistungsfähigkeit
und brauchen in der tat wahrscheinlich
einen großen großen hilfsplan um diese
situation zu bewältigen in essen denken
sie auch daran nachts manche ampel
auszuschalten kleinvieh macht auch mist
russland und die ukraine haben sich
geeinigt nicht auf frieden aber wenn
diese einigung hält ist heute nachmittag
vielleicht der drohende hunger in der
welt etwas gelindert worden die
vereinten nationen die hatten ja vor der
größten hungersnot seit jahrzehnten
gewarnt wenn nicht bald wieder getreide
geliefert werden kann aus der ukraine
und da ist jetzt eine lösung gefunden
worden an der un-generalsekretär
guterres selbst beteiligt war lück
wallbott berichtet aus istanbul wo die
kriegsparteien abkommen unterzeichnet
haben die leben retten sollen
erleichterung und ein zufriedenes
lächeln das gab es heute nur bei den
vermittlern den türkischen präsidenten
und dem un generalsekretär
russlands verteidigungsminister schoigu
unterzeichnete das abkommen mit eisiger
miene
ähnlich versteinert anschließend und
getrennt auch der ukrainische
infrastrukturminister cobra kopf
gemeinsam am tisch wollten sie nicht
sitzen ein gruppenfoto ganz sicher kein
handschlag vier monate harte
verhandlungen voller misstrauen
herausgekommen ist eine komplizierte
vereinbarung die un generalsekretär ich
einen hoffnungsschimmer nennt
das ist ein gutes abkommen für die
gesamte welt es wird erleichterungen
bringen für entwicklungsländer am rande
des zusammenbruchs für die von
hungersnot gefährdeten menschen
millionen tonnen getreide warten in der
ukraine auf den export weil seeminen und
die russische kriegsmarine die
schifffahrt unmöglich machen dem
abkommen garantieren jetzt beide seiten
eine sichere passage für getreide
schiffe aus drei hafenanlagen im raum
odessa durch das schwarze meer und den
bosporus zu den bestimmungshafen in
aller welt
seeminen sollen nur bei bedarf von einem
drittland entschärft werden ukrainische
lotsen sollen die handelsschiffe nach
odessa begleiten die exporte und alle
kontrollen werden von einer un
leitstelle in istanbul überwacht in der
türkische ukrainische und russische
experten zusammenarbeiten sollen für den
türkischen präsidenten erdogan er
versucht zur ukraine und russland gleich
gute beziehungen zu unterhalten ein
großer diplomatischer erfolg
ich hoffe dass dieser gemeinsame schritt
den wir heute mit der ukraine und
russland gemacht haben ein wendepunkt
sein kann und die hoffnung auf frieden
neu belebt
auf russischer seite mit dabei war
erneut der milliardär und putin
vertraute abramowitsch in der ukraine
hoffen die menschen jetzt auf eine
schnelle umsetzung des abkommens es
schwinger aber auch unsicherheit mit
putin wort hält so die
grünen-politikerin und
bundestagsvizepräsidentin
göring eckardt heute in odessa
haben schon alle sehr darauf gewartet
natürlich besonders diejenigen die am
hafen arbeiten und sich fragen wie
werden unsere nächsten wochen jetzt hier
funktionieren können endlich die schiffe
die schon beladen sind losfahren und
können wir endlich abtransportieren auf
der anderen seite muss man sagen alle
politisch verantwortlichen hier fragen
natürlich auch wird dieses abkommen auch
eingehalten in den silos und lagerhallen
der ukraine liegen hunderte
schiffsladungen getreide aus dem letzten
jahr da konnte die ukraine noch aus
einem dutzend häfen exportieren jetzt
bleibt nur odessa und auf den feldern
wartet schon die neue ernte
und da die bundestags vizepräsidentin
katrin göring eckardt die gerade im
beitrag ba heute in odessa war der
letzten freien hafenstadt der ukraine
haben wir für das heute-journal update
mit ihr gesprochen läuft um 0 30 uhr im
zdf und jetzt schon auf zdf heute
und hanna zimmermann beginnt ihren
nachrichtenüberblick mit einem konflikt
der offenbar nie endet so scheint es
geht mal wieder um den exit die eu hat
vier neue
vertragsverletzungsverfahren gegen
großbritannien eingeleitet hintergrund
ist ein streit um das sogenannte
nordirland protokoll brüssel wirft der
regierung in london vor in wichtigen
teilen dagegen zu verstoßen
dabei geht es auch um zollvorschriften
die im zuge des brh exit festgelegt
worden waren um eine harte grenze
zwischen nordirland und dem eu staat
irland zu vermeiden die
vertragsverletzungsverfahren können zu
einer klage vor dem europäischen
gerichtshof führen und mit einer
geldstrafe enden
nach washington dort wurde
ex-us-präsident trump im
untersuchungsausschuss zum sturm auf das
kapitol weiter schwer belastet in der
anhörung warfen die zeugen trump während
der entscheidenden stunden des capitol
sturms absichtliche untätigkeit vor
trotz aufforderungen seiner berater habe
er nicht reagiert und stattdessen die
krawalle im fernsehen verfolgt mehr als
drei stunden hatte trump am 6 januar
2021 gewartet bis er den gewalttätigen
mob per video ansprache aufforderte
friedlich zu bleiben
nach der kritik des vatikans am
synodalen weg der katholischen kirche in
deutschland hat das präsidium des dialog
format den reformprozess heute
verteidigt und erklärt seine pflicht
klar zu benennen wo änderungen notwendig
seien ein deutscher sonderweg werde
nicht angestrebt irritiert zeigte sich
das präsidium darüber dass der heilige
stuhl eine direkte kommunikation mit dem
synodalen krieg bisher verweigere der
vatikan hatte gestern erklärt dass der
synodale weg nicht befugt sei reformen
durchzusetzen die die leitung oder die
lehre und moral betreffen
bundesverfassungsgericht stehen in der
nächsten zeit gleich mehrere
richterwechsel an den anfang machte nun
heinrich amadeus wolff der heute
feierlich in sein amt eingeführt wurde
im juni war der 57 jährige jura
professor der uni bayreuth vom bundestag
in sein neues amt gewählt worden auf den
richter andreas paulus der nach
zwölfjähriger amtszeit verabschiedet
wurde
[Applaus]
wir haben die sendung mit reisechaos
begonnen doch in den ländern in die
viele deutsche in urlaub fliegen da
herrscht ganz anderes chaos
in nordafrika begann vor zwölf jahren in
diesen staaten der arabische frühling
die das damals hieß weil sie dort ihre
herrscher los wurden durch die
arabellion aber einen arabischen sommer
um im bild zu bleiben hatte nur tunesien
es war das einzige land in dem die
demokratie halbwegs gefestigt
bis jetzt denn der präsident will die
verfassung so ändern dass er mehr macht
bekommt allen acht fürchten viele am
montag soll darüber abgestimmt werden
thomas walde ist für uns in tunesien
eine merkbare erschöpften land
diktatur diktatur sorge treibt sie heute
abend in tunis auf die straße dass die
demokratie in ihrem land bald keine mehr
ist
wir fürchten dass wir zur diktatur
zurückkehren und zur gefährdung der
menschenrechte
ihr zorn richtet sich gegen den mann der
allgegenwärtige ist in tunesien
präsident karsai jetzt strebt eine
verfassungsänderung an die ihm
umfassende rechte einräumt kritik daran
weist er zurück
es ist paradox dass einige in den
vergangenen wochen von tyrannei und
diktatur sprachen während sie selbst
doch sicher sind und sich frei äußern
können
doch freiheit und sicherheit werden
schrittweise von sayed eingeschränkt das
parlament geschlossen seit er es
suspendiert hat und diese richter sind
im hungerstreik aus protest gegen
angriffe des präsidenten auf die
unabhängigkeit der justiz
der bahnhof
57 richter ohne disziplinarverfahren per
dekret zu entlassen das soll alle
richter einschüchtern es soll sie unter
kontrolle bringen indem man sie
terrorisiert da heben dabei war tunesien
einst eine hoffnung die einzige
demokratie nach dem arabischen frühling
wie ihre in medien war justizminister er
gehört zur islamischen ennahda-partei
und ist gezeichnet von der haft nachdem
ein militärtribunalen abgeurteilt
hat
wenn die stabilität in tunesien jetzt
bedroht wird dann bedroht dass die
stabilität im gesamten nordafrika und im
mittelmeerraum hb doch viele menschen
verbinden heute mit demokratie in
tunesien an den wirtschaftlichen
niedergang eine krise die man überwinden
müsse egal wie
gucken sie dieser keks kostete vor einem
jahr einen dinar jetzt kostet er einen
die nach 50 die hälfte mehr weil es
keinen zucker gibt ich bin für die
verfassungsänderung wir müssen etwas
ändern nach zehn jahren
ich werde für die verfassungsänderung
stimmen denn die politik und die
wirtschaft sind total festgefahren
die demo gegen den präsidenten und seine
verfassung endet der wahl in einer wand
aus polizisten das sieht danach aus als
folgte auch in der einzigen demokratie
auf arabischen frühling ein arabischer
winter
am abend da erreichte uns ja eine
nachricht aus der deutschen wirtschaft
die manche dann doch sehr überrascht hat
hanna du hast die details herbert diess
tritt zum ersten september als vw-chef
ab und der nachfolger steht auch schon
fest nämlich porsche chef oliver blume
frank bethmann in frankfurt was ist
bekannt über die gründe für den abgang
von dies naja unumstritten war herbert
diess schon lange nicht mehr war ein
macher ja hat immer wieder versucht
diesen großen manchmal schwerfälligen
laden volkswagen voran zu treiben ihn
fit zu machen für die zukunft was ihm
fehlte war das gespür für wolfsburg mit
seinem führungsstil eckt er immer wieder
an erlegte sich mit dem betriebsrat und
mit teilen des aufsichtsrats an bereits
vor zwei jahren verlor den posten als vw
markenchef eine erste entmachtung der
jetzt der de facto rauswurf folgt
zwischenmenschlich paste ist nicht zudem
wurde die liste der managementfehler die
man ihm anlastete immer länger einfach
an große probleme bei der entwicklung
einer eigenen fahrzeug software aber
auch die aktuelle schwäche auf dem
wichtigsten absatzmarkt china was
bedeutet dieser wechsel an der spitze
dann jetzt für den vw konzern
ja mit oliver blume kommt ein mann an
die spitze der im gegensatz zu dies als
ausgesprochen teamfähig gilt und das
gibt schon den hinweis was man glaubt in
dieser jetzt der wichtigen phase zu
benötigen nämlich einen konzernlenker
der alle mitnimmt blume bleibt zudem
porsche chef die neuausrichtung des
vw-konzerns soll er also on top stemmen
eine herkulesaufgabe wie viele meinen
vielen dank nach frankfurt
die debatte um eine nachfolgeregelung
für das 9 euro ticket ist in vollem
gange nun hat sich die nahverkehrs
branche für eine übergangsweise
verlängerung ausgesprochen und zwar bis
ende oktober
dies würde zeit verschaffen ein
dauerhaftes angebot für ein bundesweites
nahverkehrsticket zu entwickeln das
erklärte der hauptgeschäftsführer des
verbands deutscher verkehrsunternehmen
gegenüber der süddeutschen zeitung
der verband hat ein bundesweit gültiges
69 euro ticket vorgeschlagen
zur fußball wm der frauen bei der es
heute abend für schweden und belgien um
den einzug ins halbfinale ging gerade
erst wurde das spiel abgepfiffen und
feiern durften die schwedinnen sie
gewannen mit 1 zu 0 und spielen am
dienstag gegen england auf welche
mannschaft in der kommenden woche die
deutsche nationalelf trifft ist
allerdings erst morgen klar dann spielt
frankreich gegen die niederlande zu
sehen hier im zdf ab 20 uhr 15
bei der tour de france konnten sich
heute die gastgeber über ihren ersten
etappensieg freuen der franzose
christophe laporte siegte auf der 19
etappe mit einem strand kurz vor der
zieleinfahrt der der nicht unters winkel
gold konnte sein gelbes trikot auf den
rund 188 kilometern souverän verteidigen
die gesamtführung dürfte ihm bis zum
großen finale am sonntag kaum noch zu
nehmen sein
sodass waren voller nachrichten freitag
hier geht's jetzt weiter mit den zdf
comedy sommer und gegen 0.30 kommt dann
das heute-journal update heute
ausnahmsweise auch mit wulf schmiese die
anfangs gesagt weil die anderen alle weg
sind machen sie's gut
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen zum wetter heute
abend ja was war das für eine woche 40
grad in hamburg übrigens wurde in europa
noch nie so weit nördlich mehr als 40
grad registriert und wir schauen mal was
die temperaturen morgen in europa so
machen hitze haben wir vor allem im
südosten mit um die 35 grad aber auch
auf der iberischen halbinsel baut sich
ein neue hitzeglocke auf der morgen im
süden um die 45 grad wir liegen aber mit
temperaturen um die 25 grad im moment
mitten drin denn uns erreicht heute
nacht so eine kleine tiefdruck störung
und zwar zieht es von west nach ost über
uns hinweg bringt hoffentlich etwas
regen aber auch gewitter danach kommt
allerdings schon wieder ein ausläufer
des azorenhochs und beruhigt das wetter
heute nacht im norden wie auch schon den
ganzen tag über zweigeteilt 11 bis 14
grad etwas kühler im süden eine mildere
nacht bei 15 bis 19 grad und wir haben
eben jetzt schon aus den alpen heraus
diese teils kräftige schauer und
gewitter lokal mit unwettergefahr jetzt
ab dem späten abend da kommt dann aus
dem südwesten noch mal eine neue schauer
und gewitter welle die sich über die
mitte ausbreitet und morgen vormittag
dann den osten erreicht nachmittags
ziehen hier die schauer und gewitter
dann raus es entwickeln sich allerdings
nach einer kurzen wetterberuhigung
zwischen dem erzgebirge und dem
alpenraum nochmal neue schauer und
gewitter das ganze bei 20 bis 30 grad am
sonntag beruhigt sich das wetter nimmt
anlauf um am montag im südosten noch
einmal 36 grad zu erreichen